alors je vous montrais des appartements
des chroniqueurs ok allez devoir trouver
à qui appartient chaque appartement
je vous le dit chez vous moi j'ai été
choqué j'étais daily show alors regardez
premier appart
alors je suis là c'est qu'il recherche
appartement de garde ça s'équivaut
garçon garçon sait qui c'est qui bien
que les bars de la whey et un chien
wiimote et raclette ces tonneaux alors
c'est qui est reconnu les gens me jean
mi temps web ces gens me demandent à
voix haute au rail est modeste mais un
mois là non je vais peut-être vous non
mais attendez juste moi j'ai préféré
commencer pas mal voilées vois pas ce
que vous allez voir le reste c'est chaud
attention deuxième à parce que regarder
bien tous les indices regardez bien le
dire ma part c'est à qui ça ouais ouais
ouais la ccc géraldine maillet
géraldine maillet à une chose que je
n'ai pas une bibliothèque mais c'est bon
je ne la vois pas gagner mais bon j'ai
vu que je sais que vous avez une
bibliothèque il est vrai ça quétaine les
femmes et où et comment vous allez bien
mais les tableaux comme ça sur les murs
j'adore mon groupe d'amateurs de tableau
et dites moi juste eu la chaise la cc
pour un mec qui n'a jamais sonné ça
d'ici là mais qui se comporte mal aise
jumeaux péter tout de suite soit fait
pour mettre les manteaux vous avez avec
votre fiancée ben oui on habite en
séance
ouais ouais ouais ben yahya un maillot
du psg ce que voit la vie sauf moi
j'allais lancement j'habite avec une une
comédienne et sa soeur et son bien s'est
agacé c'est d'ailleurs attention alors
là les mecs
regardez jusque là vu le garçon vont en
l'air total en garde à vue sur la
parcelle non guillaume genton
mais
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas moi
1 en fait guillaume genton il va
vraiment falloir attendait en fait j'ai
des chiens ils ont besoin de place c'est
pour ça les gens sont une dynastie mono
je serai mario testino genton non mais
je travaille c'est beau mais c'est bon
avec vue sur la tour eiffel
mais ni lui aussi la une bibliothèque
mais ya pas trop de l'ira non ouais
j'aime pas c'est sur ces surnoms mais
lui l'a fait mais lui l'a mérité
ce regard là on va trouver tout de suite
isabelle isabelle excusez moi le sapin
[Musique]
en effet ce n'est plus le faire que le
27 décembre
donc moi il me restait jusqu'à fin mars
a commenté je vais pas y aller rech
partout et bien dites moi la une du
daily qu'il ya eu droit il ya eu un
petit dégâts des tous les candidats
possibles et un mari deux bords denning
donc du coup moi j'en mange plus non
plus aimé la cuisine sur la tête de ma
mère et on dirait dans l'hérault
d'interagir et notes inédites enquête
sur le sujet
[Applaudissements]
l'accusé quatre roquettes et des dieux
et gêne fraude et ce à la halle à leurs
chevaux ces fermetures à jake et maggie
ouais ouais bah très bien c'est quoi
c'est qui les remet à herrère machin de
l'herbe à chat merci et va très bien en
tout cas bravo re attention à regarder
alors là là on va avoir de la vienne
carrière pour voit tout de suite
yann cariou car elle est la langue la
mairie s'assécher benjamin castaldi bail
annuel à eybens comme chez hill et qu'il
a plus d'eau des mails à 14 h
elle m'a dit moi on se fait plaisir mais
c'était une petite bicoque sympathique
paraît que vous allez être je m'en vais
chercher je suis locataire mais je suis
chassés de chasse et six mois il ya
beaucoup de gens ignorent qu'ils sont
maudits qu'est ce que vous avez fait
alors je vais vous dire ce que je mets
est allé en fait j'ai voulu faire des
frites avec la femme
we are fait attention que j'aime une
friteuse qui paie donc posé sur le feu
j'ai pris la friteuse et je n'ai posé
violemment sur le sur le voilà et donc
l'huile c'est donc me sens mais sur mes
poignets chez brûlés au deuxième degré
d'accord voilà non mais moi je me suis
brûlé n'ya pas content mais très très
fort vraiment regarder encore la
cicatrice on avait tellement de la
vapeur d'une bouilloire ce qui m'a sauvé
c'est l'huile de coco
non il ya une chanson sur chaque pomme